The United States has an opportunity in
Libya. Resolving the Libya crisis is a
low-risk, high-reward option to weaken
Isis and al-Qaeda.
Libya's challenges are complex, but
fixable,
and solving them will have positive
effects on three continents. The U.S.
tried to defeat Isis in Libya, and to
contain the regional impacts of the
Libyan civil war. It failed. America backed Libyan partners
that had one eye on fighting Isis and
the other on seizing territory. Conditions
that led to the rise of Isis in Libya
remain, and al-Qaeda is building a base
under the radar. Russia looks to use its
growing military and economic influence
in Libya to undermine NATO in the
Mediterranean and pressure the EU. Libya
could be the place for the U.S. to
strike a major blow against Isis and al-Qaeda.
A smart intervention to end the
civil war and rollback both groups is
the best option. The U.S. should take
back leadership and coordinate its
allies and partners to shape a durable
outcome. The alternative is an unending
and expensive counterterrorism campaign.
What role should the U.S. take in Libya, if any? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and
be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.